now pressure has been mounting on tech
giant facebook after a former employee
francis haugen turned whistleblower and
revealed to the us congress a business
model she's called a threat to society
a message has resonated here in europe
where lawmakers have for years been
looking for ways to regulate the social
media company on monday she addressed
the parliament of the british as she
addressed a committee of the british
parliament and testified that facebook
intentionally pushes hateful ads to
increase profits and hides it from users
and investors
one of the people who's gained something
of a reputation for standing up to the
tech giants
is the european union's executive vice
president for a europe fit for the
digital age she's been eu competition
commissioner since 2014 and she's here
in berlin but welcome to dw mr vestaya
uh i know you're currently investing
thank you very much thank you you're
currently investigating whether
facebook's access to so much of our
personal data gives it an unfair
competitive advantage and this week as i
say we've been hearing from the face
from the facebook whistleblower who
accuses mark zuckerberg of having
unilateral control over three billion
people so
we'll start with a simple question is
facebook too powerful
not for our democracy
if we stand together then we can make
real changes
and
just to make facebook assess the risk
that they could pose to young people's
mental health and to have you know
external people looking into that
assessment to see if things have been
corrected that would be an important
step forward
okay
we don't have that and i i know that you
and the eu have been pursuing facebook
and others for some time
what do you need to do now to rein it in
well we have had you know competition
cases
but that is not enough we also need to
regulate much tighter
if we are dealing with someone who can
have an immense influence both on mental
health but also how our democracy
develops
and this is why now the european
parliament and the european council they
are considering two pieces of
legislation that we the commission have
put in front of them in order to sort of
to to make the the traffic rules of of
the internet
uh to preserve freedom of expression
but to get rid of all the things that
are illegal
offline because they should not be
illegal online they should not be legal
online either
is facebook
so big that it should be broken up
should is it time now to do that
well that would take us probably to
court for years with no end uh what is
important is that we can take action now
so that things changes
that smaller businesses can get full
access to the market and that the things
that are damaging in social media that
the companies take their responsibility
because with the kind of power that
facebook holds of course also comes
responsibility to deal with things that
poses a risk to people
so what do you you mentioned that
there's two pieces of legislation that
that you've put in front of the european
uh parliament
briefly what are what are the two the
two aims then
well for the first which is called the
digital services act is to make sure
that when digital services are provided
like
social media services like the facebook
services that's on the one hand side
there's freedom of expression on the
other hand side that illegal content is
taken down but also when products are
being sold online that we you know that
they are safe as safe as if you go into
a toy store on main street and the
second piece of legislation the digital
markets act will open the gates
that big companies are keeping right now
uh making it more difficult for mids and
small-sized businesses actually to get
to their potential customers in in an
open economy of course you need to get
to the customers without someone uh
keeping the gate for you um
you've uh what you've made your name
pursuing these these big tech companies
but last year apple appealed against a
13 billion euros in back taxes
that was something that you imposed i
mean did you get that wrong or does
apple just have better lawyers
well that is now for the european uh
court of justice uh to decide
because
we appealed
in in due respect of the general court
of course
that decision
we do our best to make sure that our
cases they will stand up in court
we are obliged since the union is built
on the rule of law that goes without any
question but of course the court can
disagree with you that is the risk that
that i know uh that is there but of
course we need to we need to try to pull
through if we think we have a good and a
strong case than to dare to take a
decision all right and you were being
discussed as a potential european
commission president at one stage does
that job still interest you
well you know when i didn't get it uh i
considered for 30 40 seconds should i be
bitter and angry about it or should i
get on with uh with a very privileged
job that i have right now and i took
that decision to pull through and see if
i can make myself useful for for
european citizens when it comes to
digital and competition and i'm really
really happy with the job that i have
right now okay so that wasn't it wasn't
quite a no but we we thank you for
joining us
margrethe vestaya executive vice
president of the european commission